you really need to come check this out
it's a lot of fun
when he was 16 just I was raised here
pretty much pretty almost born here just
been around racing my whole life and
this has been about like a second home
that's always dangerous you know you
have to be real good at timing to go
through the crossover and also have a
lot of trust and the other drivers and
did not it doesn't always work out for
you but usually if you're racing with
these guys long enough because it's
usually pretty safe safer than what it
looks like but figure eight racing
always got to keep an eye out on on the
crossover and it's always just racing
and focusing on racing the car in front
of you trying to game are built just for
this application so they're they're
built with a lot of safety and openstep
but obviously it's it's racing or going
fast for a racing tire and we're doing
figure eight so it's always extremely
dangerous but it's not as bad
publicizes mblaq I'd like to see every
time he is being born some I believe
that a lot of people are gonna see this
racing to do it and see an ash particles
sure this would bring a lot more
excitement